we have a child in the Oval Office not a
president and we have actually a child
with a particularly poor attention span
we've already learned many times that
Donald Trump is watching TV all the time
but there's now a report out that Donald
Trump once just walked out of a meeting
with Paul Ryan to go watch television in
his private dining room this is back
when Republican Congressman Paul Ryan
was Speaker of the House and he went to
the Oval Office and he was explaining to
Donald Trump what the Republican health
care bill proposal had in it and Trump
according to a former White House
communications deputy communications
director Paul Ryan went on for about 15
minutes and this is according to cliff
sims and Trump sat there sipping on his
diet cokes and sort of looking around
and eventually Donald Trump just got up
and walked out of the room and went to
his private dining room and turned on
the TV and just started watching
television and Mike Pence was also in
the meeting Mike Pence had to go over
and grab Trump and convince him to come
back to the Oval Office to finish his
meeting with Paul Ryan and this is a
sort of interesting and notable anecdote
but it's not surprising it's not hard to
believe it's exactly what we've been
hearing from anybody who knows Trump's
routine as we've learned about it and
what I am thinking back to is how Barack
Obama had to work so much harder than a
normal president to overcome all of
these hypocritical attacks from
Republicans the smears about Obama being
a foreign communist socialist Muslim
Indonesian and all that stuff
Obama was staying up late reading
reports getting up early reading books
day night all the time
Trump arguably hasn't read anything his
entire presidency we've learned that he
gets this bogus presidential daily
briefing with a couple bullet points and
a picture or two on it he doesn't read
books he doesn't listen to staffers he
doesn't often even listen to other
elected officials as we're learning
Barack Obama was slammed for his
relatively modest vacation days and then
Trump setting records in terms of the
number of days he's taking off and the
cost of those golf trips it contradicts
what Trump said he would do during the
campaign he said he'd be at the White
House all the time he
be working working with no brakes and
Republicans don't even care that he's
doing the exact opposite and I was
thinking about this and you know the
obvious double standard and there is a
really big one but you can't even talk
to Republicans about double standards
anymore if you bring up the double
standard of trumps vacation time if you
bring up the double standard of Trump
exploding the deficit while claiming he
would fix it and criticizing others for
the debt and deficit or whatever else
there's a deeper problem here which is
that even if you can point out a double
standard on a particular issue much of
the American right has bought into the
idea that problems aren't complex that
problems are simple and that the
solutions are simple and that you don't
really need a president who studies and
reads and consults and learns they have
bought in hook line and sinker to the
idea that you just need someone with the
right seven-word talking point build a
wall band trans people from the military
bail on Syria cut taxes and Obama care
whatever it is and when you believe that
solutions are as simple as the American
right believes that they are you no
longer care about double standards by
the president you no longer care about a
president who doesn't read or spend time
learning about any of these issues and
that's it okay
it's a worldview that's not based in
reality and it underlies this entire
sort of small government [ __ ]
presidents are okay industrial complex
which we saw first with george w bush
that was nothing compared to what we're
seeing under donald trump bush at least
read the wrong stuff I'm not
romanticizing george w bush but at least
he read and listened to advisors they
were horrible right-wing neocon Warhawk
advisors but he at least handled this in
a more reasonable way in the back of
this there is this underlying issue of
Republicans buying this ruse that the
solutions are always really simple and
also when you hear that Donald Trump is
just wandering out to go watch TV I mean
that's the type of
you think about when you are aware of
someone's cognitive decline so this of
course continuing to raise more
questions and concerns for people on the
Left people in the middle and on the
right who are sort of connected to the
realities of what we should expect from
a president but if you believe that all
the answers are simple and you think
that as long as you've got the right
single talking point nothing else
matters you're probably not going to be
hugely concerned by this revelation
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink asam / Pakman if you've not
already heard about blink Asst it's
amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good also bunk by
Kevin Young useful in preparing me for
the pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
is comm slash Pakman if you're watching
on youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n